supernatural monsters are on the loose
practitioners of the arcane arts are
here to bring about the end of the world
sinister paramilitary forces are using
paranormal objects to gain an edge over
their enemies in short things are messed
up and when the anomalous is out of line
we all know that there's only one group
you'd ever think to call the fbi's
unusual incidence unit what were you
expecting someone else sure they don't
have the resources of the scp foundation
they don't have the strategy of the
global occult coalition they don't have
the ruthlessness of the chaos insurgency
or the arcane knowledge advantages of
the serpent's hand but they've got to
have something right
right okay maybe you're not convinced
but you will be you may not respect them
yet but you'll change your tune when you
find out that the unusual incidence unit
has dealt with one of the most important
anomalies out there
scp-001 or as the true experts over at
the uiu call it ca3 short for confirmed
anomaly 3 if the evidence and files put
together by the uiu are to be believed
and who are we kidding of course they
are then they may have the answer to one
of the anomalous world's biggest
questions how was the scp foundation
actually formed but before we jump into
the mysteries of ca3 let's talk a little
bit more about the real heroes of
today's story the uiu this secretive
offshoot of the fbi america's premier
domestic intelligence agency was
personally commissioned by j edgar
hoover during the cold war why for the
same reason that literally everything
happened in the u.s during the cold war
to get an edge over the soviets hoover
was an extraordinarily powerful man in
u.s politics his tenure as fbi director
spanning the terms of eight different
presidents if he wanted to start a unit
of agents whose sole job was
investigating the supernatural nobody
would dare stand in his way everyone
always talks about the nuclear arms race
going on back in the 1960s but far fewer
people talk about the supernatural arms
race that was happening at the exact
same time world war ii coincided neatly
with the seventh occult war an important
geopolitical event that played a huge
role in shaping the global occult
coalition and a number of high-ranking
members of the nazi party were believed
to be key figures in this secret magical
war when the soviets sacked a number of
german cities as part of their offensive
campaigns in world war ii they were able
to bring back scores of anomalous items
that the nazis had been using to
consolidate dark power this didn't bode
well for the united states government
during the cold war after all the only
thing scarier to them than communists
were magical communists the u.s needed
to build up its own anomalous arsenal
and that's where the uiu came in the fbi
allocated some of its okaiest personnel
to the task most were either agents who
had experienced a paranormal encounter
out in the field or who were being
punished for some kind of heinous
mistake they'd made carrying out their
duties elsewhere despite not being the
best of the best these agents sure were
eager to get their hands on some cans
that isn't an innuendo by the way the
foundation refers to anomalies it deals
with as scps or skips the goc calls them
parathretts and the uiu calls them cans
again short for confirmed anomalies well
when it's an anomalous event or location
anyway anomalous objects like cursed
books or supernaturally powerful weapons
are referred to as carts or confirmed
artifacts and finally anomalous people
or sentient entities are referred to by
the unfortunate name of can man it may
not sound as cool but hey it gets the
job done just fine in the end while the
unusual incidence unit may lack the
knowledge strength resources and even
credit of its fellow groups of interest
that doesn't mean that it doesn't keep
track of the others in fact the uiu has
a pretty unique relationship with each
of them the goc for example is nicknamed
the suits by the uiu the official uiu
orientation states that the suits
outrank them and if they're asked to
follow an order by a member of the suits
they should just go ahead and do it same
goes for members of the fireworks which
is the uiu lingo for the chaos
insurgency unlike the foundation which
generally has the resources to go
toe-to-toe with the chaos insurgency the
uiu are rightfully terrified of them
official orders from the top are for uiu
agents to do whatever they say or they
might find themselves getting shot in
the head by a chaos insurgent or worse
next the cart shoppers also known as
marshall carter and dark a sinister
gentleman's club and auctioneer of
anomalous items official protocol is to
raid any deals being conducted by
marshall carter and dark but often times
these raids are unsuccessful because
mcnd's security force are more competent
fighters than anyone on the unusual
incidence unit payroll on the other hand
of the spectrum are the can collection
the official uiu nickname for the
serpent's hand uiu leadership recommends
against their agents staging any
one-on-one confrontations with them
official memos also contain the phrase
if they give you an order consider
following it they can probably set you
on fire with their mind and finally the
most important relationship of all is
the one they have with the scp
foundation much like the rest of the
groups of interest on their roster the
uiu is subordinate to the scp foundation
their agents happily taking orders from
them at the drop of a hat they call the
foundation the skippers but don't let
that casual name fool you the scp
foundation is so far above them on the
pecking order that they rarely even
communicate in any official capacity
when the foundation talks to the uiu
it's always through code they wouldn't
dream of letting a hapless uiu agent
helping them on any major operation but
laser agents of the foundation might
occasionally outsource work to uiu
agents if ever one of these plucky feds
receives a message starting with hey
skipper they can be sure they're about
to have a low priority anomalous case
pawned off on them the uiu are so
subservient to the scp foundation that
it has sometimes resulted in truly
humiliating mix-ups one high-ranking
member of the uiu once took orders from
a pizza delivery guy because he thought
that pizzeria's name the spice crust
pizzeria which could be shortened to scp
was actually a coated plant sent by the
foundation to deliver a message rather
than a deep dish pepperoni and cheese
incidents like this are why nobody takes
the uiu seriously but according to them
there was a time before all of this that
time ended on september 7 1954 when ca3
or scp-001 as the foundation would later
call it first appeared on the uiu's
radar it seemed to be the most standard
can you could possibly imagine an
anomalous high school building causing a
disturbance in the suburbs of small town
america the uiu received the call after
a number of students claimed the
interior of their schools suddenly
looked completely different than it ever
had before despite there being no
records of an official remodel and we're
not just talking about moving furniture
and a new coat of paint either the
official ca3 file logs a number of
changes these include but are not
limited to all the walls in the building
becoming steel reinforced concrete all
the windows being blacked out from the
inside all student desks personal
effects textbooks and any other standard
equipment left inside the school simply
disappearing in the night the entire
floor plan of the building seemed to
have shifted with rooms altering in both
dimensions and location as well as
featuring seemingly random modifications
within none of this matched up with the
building's original blueprints which
were obtained by the uiu shortly after
the can was reported but things got even
stranger for investigating uiu agents
the building now contained 17 computers
each with state-of-the-art magnetic core
ram and advanced cyber security for a
suburban high school in 1954 it goes
without saying that this was extremely
impressive but weirdest of all was the
fact that a large and seemingly
impenetrable steel wall had appeared in
the auditorium blocking it off and
leaving whatever was taking place on the
other side a complete mystery naturally
the uiu did what little they could to
investigate the matter the first
investigation group they sent inside
team ca3o5 never came back out and team
ca3o6
the team they sent in to locate and
retrieve the first team also disappeared
within the anomaly classic uiu expertise
at work almost a month after discovery
and initial containment a strange noise
began emanating from the auditorium
shortly after that the building became
filled with people all walking around
and working at different operations
eerily everyone there had a resemblance
to members of team ca3o6
the rescue team sent in to save the 12
members of ca 305 all of whom were still
unaccounted for three months later the
strangeness escalated more noises came
from the auditorium and the anomalous
people inside the building had gathered
around the steel wall within there was a
hole in the wall six feet in diameter
and every three minutes for several
hours the people in the room would
appear to simply pull an anomalous
object out of it the items were then
carried away and placed in one of the
many rooms that used to be classrooms
before being locked up the people within
the building then seemed to start
guarding these strange items others
started performing tests with what
seemed like far more advanced technology
and methods than what was possessed by
the uiu during the 1950s what was going
on here a few days later several armed
guards exited the building and began
guarding the perimeter when uiu
personnel attempted to lead an assault
on these guards they were quickly
overpowered even when advancing with
vastly superior numbers whether this was
due to the skill of the guards or the
incompetence of uiu agents is still very
much an open question though strangely
enough intel bleeding out from the
inside confirmed that the people within
were treating their anomalous items with
uiu containment and testing protocols
which is consistent with the knowledge
that ca3o5 would have had it seemed
almost as though o5 or copies of o5 were
creating a new splinter organization
from within and soon enough it wasn't
just confined to the interior of the ca3
building anymore ca6 a can man that the
uiu had been tracking outside the school
was suddenly kidnapped and shoved into a
black car by two assailants who appeared
identical to agent dixon a man who had
been a member of team ca3o6
the black car then returned to the ca3
facility and was allowed to enter into
the complex by the armed guards ca6 was
then removed from the car by the dixon
clones and placed into containment in
one of the classrooms it wasn't long
after that that the anomalous people
within the ca3 facility made direct
contact with the uiu outside they sent a
message in morse code on may 1st
1965. the people sending this message
identified themselves as the o5 council
a name that seemed to be taken directly
from the o5 recon team sent into the
facility months ago they identified the
new organization that they just
constructed within the confines of the
ca3 facility the scp foundation they
just opened their very first containment
site this new foundation expressed the
desire to become allies with the unusual
incidence unit but sadly for them it was
essentially the last time they'd ever
really be relevant if this foundation
origin story is to be believed and as
with all entries under the title scp-001
it's worth taking it with a healthy dose
of skepticism then the uiu witnessed the
birth of the organization that would
quickly go on to outperform and
overshadow them a big win for humanity
in the quest to secure contain and
protect ourselves from dangerous
anomalies but another l for the uiu now
go check out scp-001 which is the real
zero zero one and
scp-001 when day breaks for more
journeys into the endless mysteries of
scp-001